moi c'est un gadget hygiéniste qui sort
sur la maco vide c'est horrible on va
être des robocop comme ça dans la rue
vous aimez important d'habitants but de
communistes ou la
béatrice elle attendait la brèche
les idées qu'elles peuvent aujourd'hui
j'ai unique et ça
c'est bien d'abord
devant il s'agit bien des membres
chanteur quoi il avait le candide
tout à l'heure quand on parlait d are su
que j'allais dire que géraldine devait
très bien senti aujourd'hui puis
finalement j'ai toujours bien si ça
c'est les amériques est là les
américaines ont jeté au visage avec une
armée jamais j'avais une américaine une
voiture pendant des années alors oui je
te battais sont rancuniers rôle abbas et
les atrides je peux te dire qu'elle la
la la la la elle te poursuivra pendant
toute ta carrière
alors je connais alors mel c étaient des
amis égal que punir alalala n'a pas eu
hier soir elle a dû parler que de ça
chez dell ah oui avec son mec
je vais repenser bien c'est vrai
j'aurais dû réagir non c'est pas
tellement ce qu'elle a dit c'est comment
elle l'a dit c'est l'expression du
visage alors sachez que vous êtes
beaucoup géré a dit non
gérard gironell elle aime tout le monde
elle est le plus souvent je suis là dont
l'émission je me régale j'aime tout le
monde y voit la part des américains
l'américaine j'ai vécu à new york
l'adorent j'adore ça et moi aussi il
fallait toujours à new york pour ça que
c'est bon ça va ça va times square c'est
mon big band
c'est vraiment pas sinon l'arc de
triomphe c'est bon
voulez vous dire un truc de dettes pour
vous réconcilier comme ça on est avec
personnes ont écouté hier vous avez eu
des mots très durs envers robert fils
malade moi je n'ai jamais dit mais c'est
vous qui nous avez dû dire un truc sympa
et en tout pas sympa oui mais ça va
alors voilà je le vois sympa il a fusé
mais la fusée ont annoncé qu'ils
s'attendaient pas c'est comme ma mère
quand elle dit confiant mardi nous
attend pas à la chaussure toi voilà bah
c'est pareil c'est pareil voilà alors je
suis désolé si j'étais peiné ou froissé
ou voilà mais c'est quand même du tout
c'était juste une sorte de petit punch
line aucune méchanceté dans un parc
comme les excuses de will smith après la
claque on revit un peu la même chose
c'est ce que tu as envie caisse mais
qu'elle soit dans la boue et kessler
avec des clés suite au massacre ça pour
être excitant dans là haut mais non
qu'est-ce que c'est rancunier
l'américain c'est non mais l'américain
moi je me suis embrouillé avec robert
redford
ça fait 80 ans tu me parles pas
balader sans j'étais à côté pour
justement toute la différence entre les
mots et les gifs parce que les coups ça
ça peut tuer alors que les mots cela ne
tuera jamais all away sait de qui ça la
rousse
rien à répondre très vite et kaunas tu
vas être à votre santé
et celle et blondine et là les trois là
le respect et le groupe abba on se
connaît